a police officer from washington state
stabbed to death on the las vegas trip
today we are learning more about officer
tyler stephens and the man accused of
killing him the 8 news now i-team's
vanessa murphy joins us in studio with
how this all unfolded vanessa metro
police say officer tyler steffens was
stabbed to death over a dog now stefan's
police department is in mourning along
with a wife and two children he leaves
behind
what happened to tyler was senseless
tyler stefan's visit to las vegas ended
with his murder the 33 year old was an
officer at the edmonds washington police
department acting assistant chief josh
mcclure says he ranked number one in the
academy and served in the marine corps
he was a loving
father husband son sibling
friend and colleague
he is incredibly missed here in our
building already he says the department
received word about stefan's death
sunday according to this arrest report
stefan's trouble in las vegas started
friday night police say a man who was
loitering at a pedestrian bridge on the
strip was upset stefan's pet his dogs in
what that man described as aggressively
the man says stefans did it again on
another pedestrian bridge on saturday
night stephens and that man argued
detectives say freddie allen who was
nearby then stabbed stephens please
stand up if you're president freddie
allen
allen refused to show up in court monday
morning he is in custody at the clark
county detention center facing a murder
charge tyler being an off-duty police
officer doesn't make it any more
important than any other family that's
lost a loved one due to senseless
violence
police believe freddie allen is homeless
he also has a criminal history i've been
going through documents all day to
figure out more about his journey
through the court system here this was
not his first arrest i'll have more on
that coming up at 6.